There was like a three years gap between when I started Bug Bounty and when I started getting money from Bug Bounty.
Awesome. Hey, Sergey, how's it going?
Hello. Very good.
Awesome. Well, for those of you who don't know, this is Sergey Toshin, aka BaggyPro.
He's one of the big mobile hackers in the scene.
And today we're going to be sitting down, just me and him, to have a little discussion about mobile hacking and what led you on your path and all sorts of things.
So why don't you go ahead and give a little introduction?
I'm BaggyPro.
Like some time ago, I was number one hacker in Google Play Security Rewards program.
In the past year, I'm number hacker in Samsung Bug Bounty program.
And I'm also the founder of OverSecured.
It's mobile scanners for Android and for iOS applications.
Awesome. Yeah, yeah.
Well, we're going to talk about all those different things.
I have some notes written here, so I'm excited to pick each of those apart.
But why don't we just get started with sort of like how you even got into mobile hacking?
Because I'm a mobile hacker myself, and there's really not a ton of us.
Or if there are, we're very quiet in the shadows sort of types of things.
So what was sort of your introduction into mobile hacking?
How did you get started?
It's actually weird.
And I didn't plan this.
And I had no experience with mobile hacking.
But when I was 18, I was a student in a university.
I was studying math and like low level programming, like assembler programming and so on.
And when I was in school, I was working for an American company as a QA engineer.
And I wanted to find like a job, not for money, not because of money, but to get some experience, like real practice.
And I was looking for a job.
I was coming to co-engineer interviews.
I was coming to like C++ programming interviews.
And my actual resume was about junior C++ developer.
Yes, and I was clicking like everywhere, like come to interview, come to interview.
And companies were replying to me.
And some company, they had like three jobs.
It's a Unix security guy, mobile security guy, and like web security guy.
And I clicked.
I want to be a Unix security guy because it looks, it looked like more hard.
And that's why I picked this.
They called me, they told they liked my resume and they want me to come to their office.
And they asked, I believe, what do you want to do?
I told Unix security.
They told no, but they want to pick me for mobile security.
And that's how I started working in mobile security.
Oh, wow.
Okay.
So like a totally, completely, literally like almost by chance.
Yes.
Wow.
Okay.
And so you did that for, I assume, a number of years.
And then when did you find bug bounty?
So actually, this company was doing like consulting and selling the security products.
And like all of my friends in the company, like colleagues, they were doing bug bounty.
And like their salary was like one or two thousand dollars per month.
But they were getting like ten thousand dollars per month from bug bounties.
And they worked in the office just because of community.
And I said, oh, I want this.
But I was like 18 years old and I had no idea how to get money from bug bounties.
And that's why I was trying like ten times, twenty times until it succeeded.
Oh, wow.
Okay.
That's crazy.
So do any of those people still hack?
And were they also mobile hackers or did they do different types of hack?
No, they were like web hackers.
So actually, I believe the most of people, they hunt for like a specific vulnerability category.
For example, XSS or browsers or mobile browsers and so on.
I know people that hunt for XSEA only.
So I was hunted for mobile bugs.
Wow.
That's really interesting.
Okay.
So you, you know, you knew these coworkers, they were doing bug bounty.
They encouraged you.
I had a very similar experience as well, where one of my coworkers was somebody who did bug bounty.
And they were like, hey, you should, you should try this bug bounty thing out.
And I was like, oh, okay, that looks interesting.
Yep.
But it doesn't work immediately because I was coming to different bug bounties.
First of all, I had no experience.
Second of all, like in 2015, companies didn't believe that mobile bugs exist.
And that's why I'm submitting the vulnerability and to say it's not the vulnerability.
So true.
Oh, man.
This is like, I talk about this a little bit, but yeah, this is, this was something that
honestly only over the last couple of years, like maybe the last five years, has it really
started to change a lot where the like risk assessment for mobile bugs has gotten a lot
better because for the longest time they were just like, oh, you can't exploit this because
you would have to be on the device or you'd have to have physical proximity to the device
or stuff like that.
And it was like, you know, yes, but there, that is a non, like that happens now.
Like, you know, malware is a real thing.
Like people install random apps from the internet all the time.
So it's not like a non-zero scenario where it can't happen.
Yeah.
Because there are like a number of attack vectors, for example, a completely remote, like
from local network, from physical closeness, from physical access to the device and from
local access.
Yes.
It's not that it be one, but it's a vulnerability anyway.
Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
So you then started doing bug bounty and were you always doing the Google VRP or what, what
ended up getting you to the number one spot there?
I know.
So there are like three years gap between when I started bug bounty and when I started
getting money from bug bounty.
Yes.
In summertime, I got a visit to the US and that's why I wanted to visit.
I wanted to rent a Mustang, Mustang convertible, GT Mustang convertible.
And it was like a pretty expensive.
And as a student, I didn't have enough of money to like afford it.
And that's why I thought like bug bounty, let's try again.
And before that, I submitted like 20 vulnerabilities that got rated as not a security vulnerability.
And I really tried, like I was submitting like a lot of vulnerabilities.
I was describing them carefully and it worked.
And I remember, I remember a vulnerability in Jira, it's, uh, it was using, uh, any SDK that
was vulnerable to that, that's the arbitrary files.
And, uh, I submitted it to Quora it's disclosed in my hacker one profile.
I submitted it to Jira.
They fixed it.
And, uh, like from only one V specific vulnerability, I got like, uh, $10,000.
And it was, yeah, I have enough of money from one vulnerability to afford my trip and everything else.
Now you can rent the Mustang.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
It's all about setting goals.
You know, I, I love that.
I love just like having a specific goal in mind and then you just like focus on that and just
like hone in your energy all towards that one thing.
Yeah.
Because if it didn't work, I had to rent, I don't know, Hyundai, can't be doing that.
That's awesome.
Um, so you mentioned, uh, you mentioned that you're the number one hacker on Samsung right
now, is that, is that right?
Yeah.
So, um, tell me a little bit about that.
Cause Samsung is, uh, I don't think I've actually ever hacked on Samsung and they run an
independent program, right?
It's like totally operated by them.
So what, what is, uh, w w w what, what was that process?
Like what led you to start hacking so much on Samsung and, uh, w w what are sort of the
pros and cons of working directly with the company like that?
Actually, it was like super random because, uh, I had my, I have like in my life, I'm using
iPhones, but, uh, I also have Android devices and like to test vulnerabilities and so on.
And I'm using a Samsung for this purpose.
And, um, I thought like, yes, I'm not using it like every day, but, uh, I still use Samsung
and that's why it's a good target.
First of all.
And second of all, um, I had no idea about, uh, fragmentation in, uh, Android vendors, but
it appears that, uh, Android devices are completely different.
And if you take a pixel device, if you take Samsung device, if you take a, like a Xiaomi
device, they're completely different from, uh, like vulnerabilities perspective.
And that's why I was curious, uh, like, uh, are there any vulnerabilities, but it appears
there are a lot of them like device specific vulnerabilities or vendor specific vulnerabilities.
Do you find it difficult to sort of work with that attack service or did you originally find
it difficult?
Cause I imagine as you're, uh, trying to attack something like pixel or Samsung, like the,
the scope changes quite a bit.
And also those attack vectors change quite a bit where you have to start thinking about
the threat model differently, sort of from like a more of a consumer perspective, right?
Where, uh, where are the vulnerabilities within the system as a whole that you can exploit,
uh, versus just like specific applications or specific scenarios.
Um, how can you talk a little bit about that?
Um, you have like a long question, but the answer is no, uh, everything is clear because,
uh, the application are written, uh, in Java, not in Kotlin and, uh, there are no any
obfuscation and that's why it's much easier to hunt for vulnerabilities.
Okay.
That, wow.
That is not what I was expecting actually.
So, so for some context for like people who are listening, um, uh, I think a lot of people
may be unfamiliar with this, but most apps, uh, nowadays I'd say probably, I don't know,
at least 30% are written in Kotlin.
Right.
Um, so I believe for like, uh, 80% of applications, they, they are mixed, uh, they are Java and,
uh, Kotlin based.
Mm-hmm.
So I'm talking about like a big, uh, modern rich applications.
Yeah.
For example, Airbnb, uh, Tinder, uh, Google, and, uh, well like popular applications, uh,
and, uh, they rewrite their applications in Kotlin and use Kotlin features.
And then they have to skate Kotlin.
And it's like a complete mess.
Yeah.
Have you, I've noticed, so I've noticed that you're quite active on the Jadix project.
I don't know if other people have noticed that, but, uh, is that something that you
use pretty frequently?
Yeah.
And actually, um, this tool is used by the scanner and, um, it's like super important
if, uh, everything is correctly, uh, the compiled, like, uh, if the code is
obfuscated, it's okay, but it should be like, uh, compilable, uh, there should be
like correct references and, uh, because finding a vulnerability, it's like a number
of, uh, of actions of event, uh, of events and, um, like the code code flow should be
like super correct.
And if it's not correct, uh, like a, one of a hundred of, uh, uh, like important
code lines is, uh, uh, corrupted, uh, the vulnerability will be missed.
And that's why I'm being in like a Jadix developer, like, Hey guy, please fix this
specific, this specific error because, because of this, uh, I cannot detect the vulnerability.
Yeah.
That's, that's awesome.
That's exactly what I've noticed is like, I'll be hacking on something and I'll, I'll
have some like weird behavior in Jadix.
And I, I also use Jadix as my main decompiler, but I don't do the same automated level of
scanning that you do.
However, when something fails to decompile, oftentimes I'll go and I'll look and I'll
see either you have a ticket open for it to fix, or it's just been fixed and I need to
update my version of Jadix.
So that's really a, that's really an awesome thing to see where someone from the community
is interacting back and forth with the tool creator to actually improve the tool in real
time.
Yeah.
I'm actually feel always like, um, I don't know the correct word of not angry, but no,
when some guys report vulnerabilities about, uh, UI issues, like, uh, like the menu is not
correct.
And I'm thinking it's like open source project that the guy could be working on the calculation
vulnerabilities, but he's working on UI issues.
Why do you care about this?
So speaking of the UI, do you, do you use like when you use Jadix, um, I guess maybe let, let,
let me split this into two questions.
So, uh, let's say for your personal hacking, not oversecured, like automatic, automatic flow.
So are you using Jadix when you decompile apps just generally across the board?
Of course, like only Jadix and I never tried any other decompilers.
Cool.
And then are you using the GUI much or do you open it in like a separate editor?
Maybe, maybe we can, you could walk me through sort of what your hacking flow looks like if
you're approaching like just a one-off mobile app.
So actually, first of all, I'm scanning the application using the oversecured and then
I'm, uh, looking for vulnerabilities, uh, uh, that it found.
Okay.
And, um, I didn't do like manual, uh, review.
Like sometimes I need to cover like all the vulnerabilities.
Like, uh, it's our customer and we need to verify, like manually verify if everything
is correct, no vulnerabilities are missed.
And that's why I'm coming in like, uh, checking everything is correct.
Uh, no, like, uh, corrupted code flows, no, uh, decomulation issues.
And, uh, yeah, I'm like, uh, checking all exported components.
Uh, I'm checking like clipboard, uh, notification handling, uh, like everything, uh, like local
web services, uh, uh, web servers and so on.
Got it.
Uh, like if I'm manually hacking just for fun or just because I didn't hack for a long time
and I want to come back to my roots, uh, I'm, uh, like, uh, chicken with using oversecured
and then I'm opening it in JDX, uh, UI.
Yeah.
And, um, yeah.
Okay, cool.
Yeah.
So it could be like a simple vulnerability and I don't open, uh, JDX, uh, at all.
But sometimes if it's a tricky vulnerability, there are like, uh, tricky conditions.
I'm opening it, it, uh, JDX.
Yes.
Okay.
So why don't you tell me, we've talked about oversecured.
We mentioned it a couple of times, but why don't you talk a little bit about that?
Because it sounds like generally as you were doing hacking, it was sort of a natural progression
to create the product and company that oversecured is.
Right.
Yeah.
So, uh, I was doing bug bounty hacking and, uh, I was, uh, looking for vulnerabilities in
many applications and I was like lazy to do everything once again manually because there
are like, uh, uh, like thousands of files and, uh, I need to like again and again, uh, go
through like, uh, all the sources, uh, grip, uh, the same stuff.
And it was like super boring to do that like manually.
And that's why, uh, I created a tool and it was getting better, better and better.
And in 2019 Google launched, uh, it's a bug bounty programs that called the Google play security
rewards program.
And, um, I became like a number one hacker in this program because they started paying
like $3,000 for every vulnerability found in a super popular application.
And like a Google guys was asking me like, what do you think about this?
Uh, like before that, uh, because before this is that introduction, uh, they had like, uh,
15 applications in scope.
And, uh, they asking me like, how do you think if you should, uh, extend our program?
And, uh, I told maybe we need to add vendors like Google apps or Google apps or someone else
like Samsung apps.
Um, and they told me, adding like all applications that, uh, have a hundred million of its installations
increasing rewards three times.
I told guys, you're going to bankrupt.
That's crazy.
Yep.
And, uh, uh, I like started reporting a lot of vulnerabilities and they started paying a lot.
Uh, like, uh, say like, uh, privately, uh, uh, told like it was our mistakes that the, uh, started
paying like $3,000.
And right now they're paying $1,000 for such vulnerabilities.
Yeah, it's true.
I noticed that they had, that they dropped it down after they, uh, after a little while,
after, after you had farmed them like crazy, that that's really, really crazy.
So for those who don't know, uh, you know, VRP basically said any application that was,
what was it over 1 million installs or something like that?
10 million installs?
Uh, a hundred million.
A hundred million.
There were like, uh, 500 of such applications.
Right.
So basically any vulnerability that affects any of those applications, Google vulnerability
rewards program would pay you an additional bounty, even if you reported it to the original
app, right?
Yep.
So actually, um, I didn't like reporting it to the developer because, um, there were
a policy that, uh, was saying like, uh, if a company has a bug bounty or vulnerability
disclosure program, you need to report it to them first to wait until it's fixed.
And it, it was taken like months, uh, until you get reward.
And, uh, that's why reporting it's like directly to Google.
It's like a more profitable because you're getting a reward within, I dunno, like two weeks.
And you're not waiting.
You're not, uh, having like a backlog of, uh, vulnerabilities, you're not tracking because, um, I cannot say like I had a good experience with developers because they like don't care.
And, uh, Google, uh, like, uh, pushing on developers and forcing them to fix the vulnerability.
But when you, as a researcher reporting it to a developer, they like don't care.
And they say like, okay, we fixing it, but actually they not fixed it or they will be fixing it after a year.
So it's like, uh, very annoying.
And, uh, like the reporting, uh, vulnerabilities to Google.
Hmm.
So, uh, when you, when you find bugs in apps that are in that, you know, 500 plus cohort now, do you report it directly to the company or do you still report it directly to Google?
Or what, what does the process look like now?
So you, uh, you have to Google if, uh, the company has a bounty or VDP program.
And if they have, you report it directly to them.
If, uh, they don't, you report it to Google and they start their own process of validation, uh, and, uh, rewarding you for this.
Got it.
Okay.
So would you say that like a lot of the P the, the companies and apps that you were familiar with?
Yeah.
Finding a lot of bugs on that.
You've now signed them as clients onto over secured.
Actually not a lot, all of them because, uh, uh, this program was only a push to start the company because, uh, I have, I had like, uh, friends that started their own companies in cybersecurity.
And, uh, they, uh, pinging me like saying like, you have good scanner, you have a good business idea.
So start your company.
Yeah.
And I was like, uh, starting the company.
It's like, uh, where like, uh, paid taxes, like how does it work?
Yeah.
Taxes.
And, uh, when Google rewarded me, like, uh, within, I believe four or five months of work within almost a million of dollars.
Uh, start like, Oh yeah.
Like everyone is vulnerable.
I got the confirmation, like even super popular apps are vulnerable.
And right now I have money to, uh, start my company, fund everything by myself, bootstrap it.
Yeah.
And, um, I did it.
I came to America, opened a bank account, registered the company.
Wow.
And right now we'll be a developer based company.
Oh, that's amazing.
That, I mean, you really, it's awesome to see.
I love seeing when bug bounty hunters, especially, but generally just security researchers are able to turn one of their like personal toolings into a company like this, because there's so many smart people who are building so many awesome security related products.
And a lot of the time it's just for like personal use, just like what you were doing.
Like this was just to save time and effort, uh, by making your scanning a lot easier so that you could just throw in an app and do all your checks at one time.
And you could just turn that into a product and help other companies, you know, automatically just, they sign up and they pay you and get that coverage.
Yeah, but actually I had no idea like, uh, how business works.
Uh, and it appears that selling to B2B is like super hard because even if you like, uh, completely disrupt a company, if you like, uh, give them a good report, uh, they fix, uh, the vulnerabilities.
They say, thank you.
Alleluia.
Like you said, anyway, they need the budgets like for your tool and you need to talk, uh, it's, it doesn't happen immediately.
Like, uh, if you hacked them this year, maybe in next year, they assign budgets, uh, like to buy your tool.
Oh, wow.
It's like super long process.
Yes.
Yeah.
Almost like the triage process where you're waiting for bounties.
That's awesome.
Um, so, uh, you had mentioned that, uh, you disclosed the reports and, um, I think one of those that I, I have bookmarked and I go back to all the time is, uh, this, this, uh, this report that you call, I think it's golden Android techniques for URL pipe, uh, parsing bypasses or something like that.
Um, what made you want to publish that?
Cause that is just such an awesome resource for people don't know.
This is, uh, essentially, I think it's four different, um, three or four different tricks that you, you know, published for how, uh, Android will be parsing URLs or oftentimes apps will implement parsing URLs that are implicitly vulnerable to parsing problems where you can either pass in a different host story.
Or if they do, you know, dot get hosts, then it'll respond with a different host.
But if they were to do a string check, then it's different.
And so, um, I think those are really, really awesome checks.
Cause I, I reference them all the time, but what made you want to publish that?
Cause this was many years ago, right?
This was 2018.
Um, so I think you were quite ahead of sort of the, the mobile security publishing curve at that point.
Yeah, actually this, uh, this is, uh, reposted in, uh, our blog in our secure blog.
Uh, I believe the article is, uh, like, um, attack vectors on the view or something like that.
So there are like, uh, extended techniques and, uh, extended ways of hacking of securing.
Yeah.
But, um, I always publish, like, I don't have any like hidden knowledge that I use when it's dark.
You get your secrets, your secret.
Yeah.
I don't actually have any hacking secrets.
Um, and I always, uh, published everything I know, like, uh, maybe I know a way of, uh,
hacking something, but it's like, uh, super small to publish, uh, and it's super small for, for an article.
But, um, I always, uh, posted everything.
I know if it's, if I consider it's interesting because, um, I think it's like, uh, good for our world because, uh, cause there are only a few mobile hackers and I have like, uh, uh, I dunno, uh, a hundred points in mobile hacking.
Uh, so I can push someone else like, uh, to, I dunno, 20 or to 50 or to maybe 150.
Yeah.
That's an awesome point to talk about it.
Because like, uh, companies, they don't know about mobile vulnerabilities.
And when I disclose reports, I like, uh, push them and, uh, I believe, uh, they, uh, started to know that there are mobile bugs and, uh, how they look like.
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, I think so many people see mobile as sort of just another proxy for API hacking or, or web hacking where they just use it to get endpoints.
Exactly.
And that's kind of it.
And that, that, that's cool.
Like, you know, uh, that is, there are certainly vulnerabilities there, but I, I think there's just so much more depth when you're going to the real, like the level that you and I often go to where it's, you're looking for activities, you're looking for intents, you're looking for, uh, providers and, and all sorts of different, like Android specific components to find those real, like Android specific vulnerabilities, um, that provide so much more impact than just, you know, finding an ID or, or whatever.
Or whatever.
Well, not always, but oftentimes.
That's cool.
And so you mentioned your, uh, the oversecured blog posts.
Uh, this is another thing.
I have a bunch of these bookmarked.
Um, I've actually used oversecured a couple of times to scan apps.
And one of the things I really like is that it will link out to the different blog posts about different findings that it has.
So if it finds, uh, you know, access to app protected components, it'll say, Hey, here's a link to the blog post where you can read all about in depth.
You know, what does this look like?
Uh, you know, what is, uh, an exploit scenario look like?
How can you identify these types of things?
What's actually going wrong?
How can you fix it?
Like it's a huge, huge resource.
Um, have you found that, uh, there are things that you end up referencing in your own blog posts?
Well, while you're hacking, or is that sort of just something that you've written down and published and just goes out there?
Um, so all the blog posts, uh, they're like results of, uh, hacking and, uh, like, uh, hacker, like previously I was hacking like a number of applications and I was looking like common, uh, like, uh, common patterns of vulnerabilities.
And, uh, I created like, uh, rules for detection and, uh, then I started detecting it.
And right now I'm like extending and extending and extending, uh, uh, the rule base.
And, uh, like right now I'm, uh, hunting for like a new, uh, vulnerability patterns because like, uh, don't know any other, uh, patterns.
And that's why I like, uh, taking the sources, uh, checking it, everything.
If it was your question.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, totally.
I, I was going to ask something about this as well, because I think one of the things that I felt as well is that over time, uh, mobile hacking, like,
there's, there's not many new vulnerabilities that I see coming up.
It's a lot of the same types of patterns and the same types of vulnerabilities that are appearing again and again.
Have you noticed any new common issues or things that you are seeing a lot more now that you didn't used to see, or is it kind of a lot of the same?
Hmm.
I think I did, uh, the last, uh, vulnerability, like a category about, uh, two years ago in, uh, Android and for iOS.
I'm like, uh, it's like a, a big, uh, sphere.
I'm like right now researching and I'm like actively adding new categories to iOS because, uh, it's like a research sphere.
But, uh, coming back to Android, uh, um, so I think everything is linked because, uh, like you have, uh, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your,
your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your, your
to that the iOS sphere now just because it's a whole new space.
It's a whole new area of research.
It's all new, you know, everything.
Have you found that a lot of things that worked on Android also have sort of like a parallel into iOS or they work there, but in a different way?
I believe there are like 80% of intersected categories in Android and iOS,
but the biggest problem of Android like previously and the biggest problem of iOS right now is that there are like two types of iOS security.
First type of iOS security is like an NCO group that they hack like everything into the system of building chains, decompiling everything, reversing like assemblers.
And the second type of iOS security is like running an application, an emulator checking like a keychain flux and so on.
And there should be like a, like a different, like the right type of iOS security that like doing like normal vulnerability tracing, checking deep links.
It's not like a super critical vulnerability that giving you a route on the device, but anyway, you need to protect the application and you need to do it like more deeply.
Yeah.
Okay.
And have you, have you done any of that like deep level decompiling type of research on iOS?
Cause when I think about iOS hacking, I think that there's a really large section of it that is essentially zero day research and looking for bugs that can be used for jailbreaking the system because it's not like, it's not easy to root it by default.
Is that something that you've spent any time looking at, or is it primarily the applications themselves?
So actually we're not decompiling it because there's no like a good way to get the sources from a iOS application.
And that's why this, for example, with our customers, we go in with Android, uh, and then we say like, we also secure iOS applications and we sign like NDAs, they give them sources and, uh, they like, uh, super.
I don't know.
Afraid to give sources because, uh, they say like, we never did that before, but I say, like, uh, okay, your Android application, it's not confiscated.
It's like, uh, by default, it's open source.
So if you're an Android application, then what's the matter to deal with iOS?
I love, I love that, that strat because like so many people don't realize that you could just decompile in Android.
That's actually one of the things that I love the most about Android app hacking is I'm like a real, I'm a source code person.
I like reading the code and understanding how it works and having it all right in front of me in like an application that you could just take apart.
You know how everything works.
There's no black magic.
It's just what you see is what you get.
I love that approach to hacking.
Uh, and that's always one of the things that's really like pushed me away from iOS is that you don't get that same level of.
You know, understanding and readability, it's so much more obfuscated.
You have to do, you know, reassembly and all, all this stuff.
Um, has that been a challenge for you as well when, when moving into the iOS space?
Um, so.
Actually I didn't, uh, hack like, uh, pure IPA applications.
Like I'm not taking it, I never took an IPA file and checked for vulnerabilities.
Uh, normally I took, for example, Android application, checked like a deep links, and then I tried to apply them to the iOS application.
And sometimes it worked like, uh, there's a security, a secure check in the Android application, but there's no checks in iOS application.
And it's kind of, for example, I hacked iOS applications.
And the second vector is, uh, like, uh, uh, uh, I took, uh, sources and.
Uh, like, uh, checked for vulnerabilities, adopted the scanner to it.
And that's how like, uh, it worked.
But it's really a big problem for us, like, uh, as, uh, for a company securing iOS applications, like, uh, we.
Because we, when we develop a scanner for Android, we like taking a lot of applications.
We can analyze, we can get statistics.
Um, we can check how like some speed, like, like new experimental rule.
Uh, rules work, what's the output.
But in iOS, we cannot do the same.
And that's why we like, uh, uh, asking our customers, hello guys.
Uh, are you okay to like, uh, like we don't store sources and that's why, uh, uh, they need to like share sources.
I, uh, like, uh, via mail or via a link with us.
And that's why we analyzing it.
Uh, and like, uh, rules checking if, uh, something is wrong and there are like undetected vulnerabilities.
Yeah.
So it's harder with iOS.
Hmm.
That's really interesting.
It's a whole different problem space.
Like I, I, I really take my hat off to the people who do iOS hacking all the time because it's, it's, it's a whole different beast compared to Android.
I honestly think Android is quite a bit easier.
Um, so stepping off of that, actually, um, lots of people reach out.
They always want to be getting into mobile hacking.
Um, I'm sure this is something that people probably ask you as well, but what, do you have any tips or recommendations or things that you would suggest to people who are new to?
Maybe they're, they're experienced hackers, but they're new to mobile hacking and they don't really know where to start.
Um, I would recommend like, uh, taking all the old application, like this clip and also disclose vulnerabilities and trying to reproduce some vulnerabilities, checking logs, checking what's going on and like, uh, touching the vulnerability with your hands.
But, uh, I think it's like, uh, like a bit harder to get into mobile security because when you're hacking web, you can, uh, like put access.
It says, like super easy and you don't know, uh, to know like many things, but when you hack, uh, uh, mobile applications, you need to know like, uh, Android context or iOS context.
And, uh, you need to read the sources and, uh, like additionally, uh, you need to read, uh, the compiled sources.
And sometimes it's harder than reading like a normal, not apostate sources.
And that's why there are like a number of things you need to learn before you're getting successful in mobile hacking.
And it would take some time.
Um, and it would take like a lot of efforts from a person who wants to start mobile hacking.
But, um, if, uh, this hill is, uh, passed, uh, then you will be getting like a lot of money from the bounties because like, uh, everyone is vulnerable and there are a lot of, uh, vulnerabilities.
And, uh, zero like, uh, maybe five personal competition with you.
And if you compare it to the, uh, bug bounties, uh, there are like 500 people competition.
So true.
That's, and that hasn't really changed much either.
When I first got into bug bounty, everybody was like, oh, you, you do mobile hacking.
Like you should, you should hack on mobile because nobody does mobile hacking.
And, uh, you know, five years later, it's very little has changed.
So, so yeah, absolutely.
I'll totally echo that.
Um, I love that, that piece that you mentioned about, uh, like retesting vulnerabilities.
Do you have, uh, any ways that you identify, you know, old, old reports or stuff that people have published?
Is, are you on Twitter a lot?
Like where, where do you find, uh, reports to, to go read and reproduce?
Um, I believe there are a lot of, uh, GitHub repositories that contain links, uh, to like different disclosed vulnerabilities, uh, to articles.
And, uh, like a person needs to like check, maybe, uh, they don't understand everything immediately, but, uh, it's like you're reading something, understanding something, and then coming again and, and, and again, and again, in, in the loop until you get everything.
Awesome.
Um, had you ever done any Java programming before you started hacking on mobile?
Um, uh, like, uh, the simple answer is no.
Uh, but, uh, when I was like a school boy, I was, uh, I wanted to like to create a lot of projects.
Um, and I, let's say I, I, I didn't know anything about Terence.
I was like 10 years old and I wanted to create like my own website.
So it had to be completely free.
Uh, no lights in this, no everything.
And, and, uh, like people, uh, people have freely share like, cause there are the stuff, uh, on that website.
And then I know that the Terence existed.
There are a lot of such websites, but, um, I was, uh, really passionate about this idea.
And I, I didn't know why, but, uh, I thought that I need to learn PHP and C++.
I don't know.
It's a very interesting selection of languages.
So those were your first two.
And then you'd kind of just, yeah, I, I think one of the, one of the really challenging things about mobile is that it's, uh, especially Android.
Like you kind of almost need to know how to read code.
You don't necessarily need to know how to write it, but being able to read and understand what a code snippet is doing is really, really important.
Especially for the deeper types of vulnerabilities that we're talking about, not just AI or API, uh, you know, scanning or looking at the requests in burp or whatever.
But actually finding like figuring out what the app is doing, um, requires some, some level of understanding.
And I think that could be a big hurdle.
Uh, do you ever have to spend time like learning about new, so like, for instance, Kotlin, did you have to do a deep dive on how Kotlin works and stuff in order to, to figure that out?
Or did you kind of just adapt your tooling to figure out, you know, what does Kotlin look like at the end of compilation and just, you know, make it work with how it is?
Um, I think I never adopted, uh, the scanner to Kotlin because, uh,
when Kotlin is compiled to, uh, Dalvik, uh, bytecode, then it's decompiled to Java code and it's like, uh, it's the same to like, uh, Java code.
Uh, but, uh, there's a lot of, uh, different checks and, uh, like, uh, Kotlin stuff, but, uh, it's not important from a vulnerability detection perspective.
Um, yes, there are a lot of like, uh, synthetic classes, uh, closures that are compiled to Java classes.
Uh, and, uh, they, they look like, uh, uh, like a complete mess when they decompile, but anyway, it's not a big problem for vulnerability detection.
Nice.
Okay.
That that's really cool, man.
I'd love to, I'd love to pick your brain, uh, in depth about how, how your whole product works, but I don't want to, I don't want to board people and, uh, and have to bleep out a bunch of this episode.
So, um, yeah, we'll, uh, we'll, we'll, we'll leave the super technical stuff for off air, but, um, cool, man.
I, I think that was like most of the questions that I had, uh, was there anything else that you wanted to sort of shout out or, um, any, you know, your company, your website, your Twitter, anything like that.
Um, you can add, uh, links to my profiles and, uh, your podcast.
So you'll have all, um, all the bingo, Twitter, website, and the blog.
Perfect.
Also, we can add like some most popular repositories that contain, uh, like, uh, a set of disclosed vulnerabilities, a set of articles, uh, there are like many, my, uh, vulnerabilities in my, many, my articles, but anyways, there are like, like, uh, um, a lot of, uh, different ones.
So you can share it with the guys and they can start the mobile hacking.
Awesome.
Perfect.
Yes.
Well, we'll, we'll put those links, uh, down in the description.
Um, you can find, uh, links to baggy pros, uh, profiles, the overscrewed website, um, the overscrewed blogs, a bunch of blog posts, uh, and, and mobile security write-ups.
And, uh, if mobile hacking is something that you're looking to get into, that is an awesome place to start.
Uh, like I said, there, those are some of the best mobile hacking resources that are out there, especially that are like up to date and modern and bug bounty focused and that kind of stuff.
So, um, awesome dude.
This was, uh, this was, this was great.
I know it's early over in, uh, in Asia or Japan or wherever, wherever you're currently at right now.
So I appreciate you waking up at the crack of dawn and, uh, chugging two coffees before, before you got, you got on here to talk with me.
And, uh, hopefully you could get a little more sleep after this.
Yeah.
Um, but I woke up, uh, I couldn't talk like, oh my God.
Uh, are you, you joined and you were like, I just woke up 10 minutes ago.
I was like, do you want to get a coffee?
You're like, yeah, I'm going to, I'm going to go to the coffee shop.
I'll be right back.
Yeah.
Because yes, they landed at the 1 AM and they woke up, uh, at, uh, 7 50 AM.
So.
All right.
Well, then you, you should go back to sleep.
Uh, you, you done enough brain dumping of mobile securities.
So thanks very much.
Sergei was awesome talking with you.
All right.
Peace.
Bye.